We are recording. It is the fourth I think of the fourth month of the year. So April 4, 2018,
we've been doing these for quite some time. I hope if you're due to this platform and watching
these Zoom calls and listening to them and catching them later on the Facebook page that you do go back
and try to listen to as many as you can. A lot of your questions will be answered through those calls
that we went through. We are going to be in the process of trying to catalog them so that
you could more easily find what you're looking for. Today I'm going to talk about something near
near to my heart when it comes to disease, not just cancer. And then we're going to get to some
questions and then we'll open up the microphone to everybody. So this, you've heard me say it before
that every disease has an emotional component to it. So cancer is the same as anything else.
I wouldn't say that your difficulty motions or woods for the past cause every disease
or are even a major piece of every disease but they certainly are a player of every disease.
This slide talks about the buildup that leads to disease. And that is just woods, emotional scars
from past relationships, from things that you did to others, the things that others did to you
plus your daily stress and your worries. All these can cause problems in ourselves. They certainly
can reduce our immune response. That's very essential in getting cancer. Almost everybody that I
speak to, that has cancer, can at least tie to their, they may remember going through an emotional
troubling experience, maybe just a lot more stress at work or stress at a relationship, going through
a divorce, maybe a financial crisis, and tie that to possibly the connection of their cancer.
Remember what cancer is, is that something had to get inside the cell and affect that replication
cycle. Could be so legitimate but most of the time there's a toxin or a biotoxin involved.
And this is going on in our bodies all the time. That's why even if a person doesn't have cancer,
you could do an IVG test and you still might have a score of five. Well, if the IVG test is
measuring CPG islands, the DNA of circulating tumor cells, if I don't have cancer, why in the world
when I have circulating tumor cells? Well, the truth is something that I've said a lot of people have
said that everybody has cancer that's growing inside your body and that your immune system is dealing
with and destroyed. And whether I ever get a diagnosis of cancer meaning that it ever gets big
enough to be able to be diagnosed that would cause me ill health or that would be able to be visualized
on any type of imaging, some things had to take place. That had to continue to grow and it had to
elude the immune system in one of the ways that cancer will elude the immune system is whether
our immune system is suppressed. And one of the major things that suppress our immune system is
stress. So stress can suppress our immune response. So there's a lot of people also that will say I have
cancer. I don't remember going through any stress. I feel like I'm really good at handling stress.
And that may be true, but also I want to ask you, it may be your perception of the truth. And we
want to be careful of that. I might say I'm really good at handling stress because I've learned over
the years, you know, good ways to shelf that stress, good ways to stuff that stress, good ways to put
out a face through that stress. So people think my goodness, he had those stress so well, well inside
it might be eating me apart. And I don't even notice it myself. So one of the things when we have a
serious diagnosis, we want to start asking questions. And that's what this talk is about. And we could
talk about this for literally days. So I'm not going to cover it in 15 minutes here. But there's going
to be some points that I'm going to start stressing in a lot of my talks about the emotional side of
kids are in learning how to deal with that. So there are multiple platforms out there and different
techniques that help us get to some emotional core issues. What is obviously psychotherapy? You go to
a counselor that's talk therapy and cognitive therapy that they talk through your different issues.
And trying to dig back to your childhood and maybe you were abused or maybe you did you're an
apparent that didn't love you or whatever it was. So those are very significant issues. But to go
through a process like that could be very difficult. It could be very lengthy to get to some core issues
that way. They don't necessarily help you deal with them. It just helps you get them to the forefront
which could be helpful. But we want to be able to deal with those too. Well, we're dealing with a
serious diagnosis. Hey, I have colon cancer or pancreatic cancer or breast cancer. And you kind
of got to get to the root of this a little bit quicker. So I'm going to show you a couple of charts here
that might be helpful. So I'm going to give you a few clues on tonight's talk that maybe next time
I talk to you I'll give you a few other clues and we'll just take this invite sized pieces. So
hopefully this is going to help some people right now. So hold on a second. We have a question,
chat question. Are you aware of cancer screening? Okay, so that's totally off subject. We'll talk about
that later. Okay, so this chart right here has to do with a technique that I have used in the past
called neural emotional technique or ET. It is a technique that looks at each organ function
and you can test these organ functions with kinesiology. And the organ functions can tie to
different emotions. And this is by no way stretch or imagination perfect. But this does give us some
clues. So none of these techniques are perfect in the correlation. But they do give us some clues.
So let's look at this chart a little bit and let's help understand it. Let's say I have stomach
issues. I don't even have to be cancer, but let's have stomach issues. We're talking about stomach,
not the intestines, the stomach itself. Let's say I have stomach ulcers. Then you go on this chart.
These are the emotions, both since the stomach-spleaded pancreas are related. According to
ET procedures, the stomach could be affected by any of these emotions here. So some of them are
opposite emotions. So a person with stomach issues can have to be overly sympathetic,
can have disgust issues, expanded importance of self. And what I do with patients, what I have done with
this in the past is all I do is read these things. And I say, do any of these things jump out at you?
Just listen to your heart. Does anything jump out at you? And usually a patient, let's say they test out
with stomach issues, or let's say you have stomach cancer. You read these things, disgust, expanded
importance of self, obsession, egotistic, despair, nervous, stifled, low self-esteem. So you can see
some of these are opposites, lives through others, over-concert, hopelessness, lack of control over
events. That tends to be a huge will that jumps out for people, worried, distrust. And they might say,
oh my gosh, you know, this has been a big part of my life. In my job, this is exactly what's
happening. I tend to get blamed for things. I can't control what happens. So this is how you would
use this chart. So if I have lung cancer, tactically, I mean, historically, the lung has been associated
with grief. I've had patients that have lost loved ones and didn't grieve that loss of their
loved ones and ended up with lung issues or lung cancer. So it ties together, large intestine,
dogmatically positioned, crying, compelled to need this defensive grief. Remember, both of these
can be for each one of these grief, sadness, yurting, cloudy thinking, anguish. So you could go through
this chart like this and this may help break up things. Now again, I'll say it again, this is by no
means comprehensive. This is just one system that can help you discover some pieces, some emotional
pieces to your cancer. I have liver cancer. Is it because of anger? You could have hidden
anger. You could have stuffed anger. You could not have anger at all. It could be resentment. It could
be none of these whatsoever. But this does help you look at some of these and start asking yourself
questions. And when we talk about looking inwardly at emotional scars, emotional issues that could
cause disease, all I'm asking you to do is to start being honest and asking yourself questions.
Now usually, this should be done by yourself, not even with your spouse, because we can have it outward
face that sometimes we don't show anybody else. And we need to to get to that inward part of us
that we don't reveal to others. And that maybe something we're hiding or something we've stuffed
or something that we've struggled with for a long time, that we haven't shared with hardly even
our own soul. So learn to start asking difficult questions and get to some core issues. And don't be so
dogmanically positioned and say, this isn't me. Say, well, this could be me. Let me think about this.
If you're a believer, I highly suggest that you ask the Holy Spirit to reveal things to you. Because
many times things that happen when you were younger or even positional things that you believe in
and think about know and how you handle things now have become so habitual that we don't even
see them ourselves. So sometimes we need to get quiet and ask the Lord to reveal something to us
that we need to deal with. And I like charts like this and some other things I'm going to show you
in a second because they could just they could just kind of be an open door that you could go, oh wow,
I never thought of that. So going through these things, looking at wherever your disease is and I
don't, they're not every organ is on here. But and going through this and saying, okay, Lord,
is that me? I don't think it's me, but show it to me if it is me. Show me if there's anything in my life
that I need to deal with with this because that is what the what we need to do to start healing.
So dealing with the emotional component of your cancer is what we're talking about.
There's another way. So this is through neural emotional technique and there's a number out there
and I'm going to bring up one more today and I'll bring up some other next time. Another one is to
simply understand physiology. So if we understand the physiology of the organ we're dealing with,
that could help us understand the emotional component of it. Let me give you an example.
Let's say I have colon cancer or small intestine cancer or even liver cancer. What does those
organs do? So I gave you a little chart of basic physiology of some organs here. Those organs
of the colon, the rectum, the small intestine, the liver, what does those organs do? They get rid of waste.
So let's think of that as an emotional component. Let's say I have colon cancer or rectal cancer
or liver cancer. How have I done a good job of getting rid of waste in my life? What does that mean?
Well, let's just think about it as a believer. Let's ask the Holy Spirit about it. Lord, what does
that mean for me? Is there something that I haven't been eliminated? That I should be eliminated?
Could it be sit in my life? That I haven't gotten rid of? Could be. Could it be toxic people in my life?
That I haven't gotten rid of because I have to be a good Christian. I can't get that person
out of my life and tell them they're not healthy for me or break off my friendship. Oh my goodness,
that wouldn't be good. So there's some people that are very empathetically driven that would never
break a friendship off and they tend to be used a lot. And it's really easy for them to carry
around toxic people and not get rid of relationships that are not healthy for them. And we could
equate that too. Well, that person is going to have a greater propensity to diseases that also get
rid of waste. So if you're not really good at getting rid of waste, we're not labeling another person
as waste, but we're saying that that's something that's supposed to be disposed of in my life.
That relationship isn't good for me. Doesn't mean they're a bad person, but it means that
relationship is not healthy for me. And if I'm not good at doing that because I have some religious
hang up that I have to be so nice to everybody and I can't let people go, then I'm going to be more
prone to diseases of those organs, whether it be kids or not. So that's another way to look at
your organs. Carolyn Mase wrote a book about emotions and diseases and one of the things she spoke
about a lot was breast cancer. And that a woman's breasts are something that they give to their
children and they give to their spouse. So she did a, you know, not a scientific study, but a
little bit of a research study in asking X amount of women that had breast cancer and how many of them
felt like they were wounded by a lover or a spouse or a relationship or by one of their children.
And she found a perfect correlation. You know, you could argue, well, has it everybody gone through
that? Well, yes, really probably everybody is, but how have you processed that? So everybody has toxic
relationships. How good are you at processing them? If you're really good at, hey, I did. That
person's not really good for me and I'm not going to break off my friendship with them and just
telling us isn't working and we're not going to be friends that I can move on to another person without
having to rheumatate on that and be worried about it. And I heard their feelings and oh, I'll let
them back in and all they asked me out to a movie. Again, I'm going to go with them. Well, I thought
you weren't even hanging out with them anymore. Well, I know, but they don't have anybody else. And
you know, that's you. You're not going to get any weight in your life and you're going to be more
exposed to diseases in that organ just like the woman who may have been wounded by an ex-husband or
lover or one of their children. And how have they been at processing that and getting that out
of their life? We all get wounded and one of my pet peeves about going through psychological
counseling and talk therapy is that it seems to always want to blame somebody. We're going to
blame our parents. We're going to blame our teachers. We're going to blame our pastors. Instead of
taking responsibility and say, Hey, it's really how I perceive the situation and how I process
the situation. And that's what's really causing the problems. And I think what we could get out of
the victim mentality with our disease, then it only then can we start healing. But we have to start
facing that this is how I've dealt with things up to this point. How does it relate to my disease?
Look at charts like this. Look at charts like this. See if any of these things start matching.
Ask the Holy Spirit to start revealing to you what it is that's tied to this and start working through
it. It's a process. You don't ever just reach the other side and you're fine and you realize it.
It's all going goodbye. You'll also find that these are tend to be some of your personality traits that
got you into this situation. It doesn't make you a bad person, but it is to help shape you and say,
wow, this is a strength that I have. And this is a weakness that I have. And I want to focus on
the strength. And I want to let God fill in the holes of the weakness, but I have to admit them
to begin with. And that's how I could start healing from past things and from present things that
are caused by disease. And then lastly, on emotions on this talk, I want to talk about just
understanding and I, and I've alluded to this in both of my cancer books. And if you don't get to the
point of saying, okay, God allowed this in my life for my good somehow, I have to figure that out.
And even though I might not be able to see it completely clearly this side of heaven, I can accept that.
Doesn't mean we don't do all this work at all. This work can dig through this, but we also have to
do it with the baseline foundational understanding that God is in it for my good. He's allowed this in my
life in his sovereignty. This was no surprise to him. And I could trust him through this. Now I got
to say, what Lord do I need to learn from this? And how could you use this to bring you glory? And when
we get to that point, then it's no longer this bitterness trying to figure it out. I got to get this
figured out and worried. It's this, I want to figure this out. But and so I could not just help myself
overcome this, but I could help other people overcome this. You have to look at the bigger picture.
If your whole purpose and coming to me is solely to get rid of your cancer so that you can live a few
extra years longer, honestly, I pity you. You have to, you have to have a bigger purpose in your life
that is beyond you. And the only way I can say to have that is to ask God for it.
Because I really believe that it comes from above. Ask him for that purpose. And he will start to reveal
that to you. These are some Bible verses to hold on to. He is, you know, you could trust in him.
And he's going to show you your path. Just from my experience, he never shows me my path more than
about 30 seconds ahead of time, usually. But that's just how he deals with me. Maybe you're much more
trustworthy and he could give you your, your path years ahead of time. But I go second by second,
literally in what I'm supposed to do. I have a general picture and I continue to walk in that
picture, but he tends to tweak it all the time and he doesn't tell me too far in advance. And that's okay
because I could trust him for that, for each step. So these are some scriptures. There's a lot of them
that you can hold on to right on your wall. Really to understand the purpose of your disease is just
to go, this is God's got a purpose of this. And I'm going to walk through this regardless of what the
end game is. And I'm going to do what he tells me to do. I mean, it's truth. I do know what the end
game is. I get to go and have it. So regardless of whether I'm going to be quote unquote in remission
from this and live to be a hundred or not is totally up to him. I just need to do the things that I
need to do and leave the results to him. So I'm going to, I'm going to stop here for a second before I
go to my other slides and just open this up for any questions. And then we got a bunch of questions
people have said. So everybody's unmuted. So I'd ask you if you have background noise to
please mute yourself. Dr. Connors. Yes. On your first slide you gave the five elements.
When I started this journey with my cancer or emotional problems, a lady told me to do a Tai Chi
emotional release with those five elements. It's just slow body movements and then you sit down
and you meditate where what colors and what emotions come off. It really did. It really worked. It
really helped me out a lot. Yeah, that's great. There's a lot of techniques out there that
some are going to work better for others. You just kind of got to, you know, ask God what
is going to be best for you. And there's just go with it. But you just have to work on this
regular basis. Dr. Connors. Yes. On the take home packet that you sent with us in the notebook,
there was the personal hard examination. Uh-huh. And I'm on this for my third time. But I was silly
and I didn't make a copy of it first. I do section B and section C quite often. Yes.
Is do you have this as an electronic copy? Or if I call up there, can they mail me?
Because I can actually post it on a link. I think I could do it on post it on Facebook. Otherwise,
we could email you a link first or absolutely. Yep. Okay, because I can claim AZK 03626, it really has
changed my heart. That's great. The reason why we put that emotional heart piece in there is
I just love the book that it came from. I can't remember the title of the book that it came from.
And then it's it's not looking to blame people in your past. It's looking to
things that happened to you along the way. It may not even have been like, okay, I was emotionally
abused as a child or something like that. It's just little things that tweaked our heart and changed
our heart. And I like how they label the different hearts that you have. And understanding that
could just could just open up the door for you to go, oh my gosh, I see things so differently.
So doing that work would be an introspective like that could be extremely helpful. Okay,
you ready to move on? Yes. All right. So is everybody still there?
Yes. Yeah. Okay. All right. So I know everybody's waiting for a lot of people are waiting for
the new genetic kits. And we are still waiting for the new genetic kits. Now the software that we use
for the genetic testing has been updated now to better batch.
Okay, sorry. Somebody's outside or something. So the software that we have to look at the genetics has
been upgraded and updated to better match the version 5 of the 23 and me and the 23 and me version 5
is now testing 600,000 steps. So I'm comfortable going back to the 23 and me and tell our new kit that's
going to test over 900,000 steps is available for those that are anxious to get their genetics. So if
you're doing well and we, and you could certainly call the office and ask them, the staff will ask me whether
where I think you're at with this, that whether it'd be fine for you to wait or whether it'd be fine,
maybe better just to jump in and do the 23 and me right now. But if you, I know there's several
that have been asking me on Facebook and on these calls, whether the genetic kits available
for at least those people, you should go to 23 and me and order a kit. Now there's two kits that you
have when you go to 23 and me.com that you will have the choice of ordering the $80 kit or a $180 kit.
Both of these kits test the exact same number of steps. This one gives you their data like, oh you are
12% Germanics, 6% Irish, Eastern European, 5%. If you want that data, excuse me, it's a lot of fun
data that you can go through. You need to pay it extra 100 bucks for that data. For what we need,
we just need this. So what this is going to tell you is many things is this. I always suggest people
just do this. So it's $99 but we cannot order the kits from us because they don't let health
practitioners handle the kits anymore. It's only ordered. Of course you could buy a bit target,
but you can't buy them for your doctor. So it's just their policy. So I can't do anything about it.
So you could go on 23andme.com, you could order the kit on 23andme.com or you could go to target
and buy a kit. I think you pay $28 for it and then when you go to register the kit, you pay the
difference. So you pay it extra 70 bucks or whatever. Where do you go to order to register the kit.
So it comes to $98 if you go buy it a target, I think. And you don't have to pay shipping.
So if you go buy it a target or they sell it at Best Buy and CVS at Walbert, you'll have to pay
$98 for this kit. You'll spin it and collect the data. Just follow their instructions. So just go
to 23andme after you buy the kit. Follow their instructions. You'll do a Slime Assembly. You'll get
it in and then you will send us your your user day of password. I'll make a short video of this
and posting on Facebook too, just so you don't want to do. All right. So that's that. So those that
are anxious about getting their D&A back, if you've already done 23andme then forget this. But if
you haven't done 23andme or early with genetic kit, well nobody's done that yet, then in your real
anxious, then just get this kit and start with that. Okay. To the questions for the day, here was
another, here was one question. Is there a rife program that can balance our body and heal or
mitigate the radiation damage caused by Wi-Fi both at home, at school, computer use, etc. With this
work for adults and children, how often should we run it? Well, here's the Wi-Fi that we're really
being exposed to on a daily basis. Electrical grids, cell phone towers, our cell phones, our dirty
electricity at our house, dirty electricity coming from computers, coming from TV screens,
radio waves going through us, everything. That's really pretty much the story right there quite
honestly. And I pulled this picture off the internet, it says before and after. Well, the only way that
this would actually look like this would be after maybe a nuclear holocaust, which ducked out all our
power lines and ducked out all the radio waves and everything. But so there is nothing that is going
to make your house look like this. Let's just be honest and upfront because it's not going to happen.
So we talked about using the static, static product that we use, that the plug-in E-MF
protectors that will mitigate some of the E-MFs and some of the Wi-Fi E-MFs that are going
to your house, it's nothing's going to make it look like this now. So you just have to do your best.
Is there a RIF program? Is it really the question? And the answer is no, there isn't. So there is not
a RIF program that is going to decrease E-MFs. There's not a RIF program that's going to decrease the
Wi-Fi E-MFs. There's nothing that's going to eliminate it. But using the static, which is the best
product that we found, and the E-MF, the heat rod protectors on your phone that you could also put on
your laptop and your iPad, those are the best things that we have found. That's what we use at our house.
And that's you just got to do your best. And there's nothing else you could do. Try not to buy a
house next to high wire lines or too close to cell phone towers, but they're putting up cell
phone towers every place though. So it's pretty hard to be any farther than to buy all the way
from a cell phone tower. So it's a difficult thing you could only do your best.
Next question, please comment on the recent news about a criminal mind in coffee causing cancer.
Well, of course, if you've watched any of the news, California, in their brilliant legislature act,
have made coffee companies like Starbucks and Caribou, I don't think they have those out there, but
people conveyors of coffee to have a warning label on their coffee that coffee causes cancer.
Well, a criminal mind is what is formed from foods typically carbohydrates,
very complex carbohydrates when you heat them up. So yes, there are criminals that are formed when
you heat beans up, coffee beans up, and you will form some acrylamides. Of course, if you look at a chart
of what actually forms the most acrylamides, potato chips is up here, but in their legislative brilliance,
I don't think they are putting warning labels on potato chips. Isn't that funny, because those
companies are being able to buy them out there or something. I don't know, maybe.
French fries, look at the acrylamides that can be formed with French fries, soup mixes, snack foods,
chocolate products, crackers, nuts and nut butters, bakery and bakery products. Well, coffee's
way down here. Why are they making them label coffee products? Because they're a bunch of idiots. I
don't know. I didn't say that. Take that back. I'm sorry. But it's insane. So yes, do acrylamides,
could they be cancer-causing? Well, in truth, if you inject labose with any high concentration of
any chemical, they're probably going to form cancer. Well, why did they ignore all the millions of
studies that are out there about herbicides and roundup? And you don't have to label that at all,
and you don't have to label GMO products at all, but you label because of a possible acrylamide
connection with coffee and cancer. I'm sorry, but did my test eat it? Of course, I only have had 500
cancer patients, but that nobody's had cancer because of acrylamides. So it's just ridiculous. The
amount of things that we're exposed to on a daily basis, and this is a miter player compared to
this kind of stuff that's going on, but because these guys control and pay off the legislature,
these guys can do anything that they want. And Monsanto basically runs this blasted country. So
yeah, I'm a little bitter, I guess, about that, because we just see it too often.
So that's nice to be able to about acrylamides. I don't have anything else to say about that.
So let's open this up and let's hear some questions before we say goodbye to the
today. Any questions? Dr. Conor and David out of Massachusetts. I'm sorry, we're not taking any calls
for Massachusetts tonight. So it's actually, it's actually Rhode Island now. Okay.
I'm just a little question regarding the 23 me. The turnaround from whatever call last was 30 days,
might be more that's still the case as far as you know. Yeah, it's still in the case as far as I
know. So it's, it's, it just depends on really, they're advertising. So it depends on, if they,
you know, during the Super Bowl, they put out some ads and then they were hit hard and now it's kind
of mellow. So it'd be a good time to get attested. Probably now it would be about two to four weeks,
probably. In the middle of the week, that's right. We're all kind of trying to apply it.
That's not fine. Hey, listen, the other thing I want to ask you is one thing that I'm kind of
resting with is pain management at this point in my pelvis and one of my legs. And so I have recently
started some of the marijuana products, topical and a pincture and it seems to be helping. But
is there anything on your side that I might incorporate? I've also been using a mobile counter like
etc and things like that, but I feel like I got to get off that stuff. So you go to something a little
cleaner. Probably the most effective natural pain management product is going to be marijuana.
So some people have had good success with CBD. But most people have better success with something with
some THC in it. So we've alluded to this in the past as well that sometimes smoking,
marijuana or just a couple of pups of a pipe of marijuana or hit a edible can be more effective
than some opiates with pain management. We've gotten some people off of opiates doing it that way.
CBD is readily available in capsule form or some ligual form that doesn't make you feel
loopy or anything, which some people don't like about smoking the marijuana. But you usually have to
take a fairly higher dose of it and CBD gets to be kind of pricey. So that's what tends to be a little bit.
Right. Well, I've gone to a couple of dispensaries at this point. I've gone through the process of getting
a permit, let's say, so that I can buy at the dispensary. It's quite regulated by the way.
So we've been talking about the THC part of it, which is the cycle at active part of all this.
I find even with a tincture that I use under the tongue and one is the topical that I use.
I also did buy what they call flowers, which is the weed itself. Sometimes I've smoked a little
bit just before bedtime. But the more THC is only the more psychoactive. And I find even with the
tincture, which is a one-on-one combination to minimize the activity, the psychoactivity,
it still gives you a, what they, what they refer to as a body high.
Sometimes that kind of gets in the way. It's fine if you're getting ready for bed a couple hours from
now, but during the course of the daytime. It's hard to function, it is, yeah.
It is. But I will say that it has been reasonably effective. So I'm looking to explore more, but
that's really been a downside for me at this point. So you can make it into, put it into a
suppository, coconut oil, and freeze them. And because the oil belts at 75 degrees,
so that you use it as a suppository, you won't have quite so many psychoactive issues with it.
Dr. Clarence, this is David's wife also from Massachusetts.
Why is the cancer painful in the, you know, if it is metastasized cancer from the prostate
to the pelvis area that's moving down, it's like why is cancer painful?
So what causes pain? So pain is caused from a stimulation of receptors.
You have different pain receptors on your skin that are protective. So when you feel
an irritant, you, we call it pain, and you will then move away from that irritant.
Pain is caused from inflammation in expansion. So let's say I have, so let's say I have prostate
cancer that's metastasized to the bone. If there is expansion of the bone, which is osteoclastic
activity, breaking down in the inflammation of that area, that will cause pain.
So let's say I have colon cancer. What would be the pain caused in colon cancer? It's expansion of
the lumen. So that's the only thing that would cause pain that's the only fibers that you have
in that area. Now there's some people that have cancer that don't have pain at all because the
area that they have cancer does not have any pain fibers, and they have plenty of room for expansion
in that area. So it has to affect the nerve in a certain way, but usually it does depend upon the
organ. So bone pain has to do with breakdown of bone and affecting the nerve diverse that way.
Organ pain usually has to do with inflammation in expansion.
Okay. So yes, you're trying to mitigate the pain. Is that really solving the problem? Well,
my problem painted, I don't want to have pain. So we don't want to have pain. That can drag
a person down real quick. But you do want to look at the pain as the pain is a side of a problem,
right? Right. So we want to do everything we can to deal with that side of the problem, but you still
want to get rid of the pain, but you're not ignoring the problem. You still want to get rid of the
pain, because you don't want to make it out. When it does feel like if somebody mentioned the
inflammation part of it, that's actually what he was like to me. Even before you had mentioned the
inflammation part of it, that's been kind of my impression of it. So is everything else additional
I can do to just get rid of it? Some of the things that will decrease inflammation. So you think of
just the standard something like ice could that help? So cryotherapy, coldness can be beneficial
to decrease the pain. Also, even something like a tens unit can stimulate tens units, stimulates at
a certain wave form to stimulate it in a dwarf in production that can be natural pain relievers.
Also, things like that are natural anti-inflammatories like Boswellia, Ginger, Curcumin,
Stiggy Dental, those kind of things can be good, but you have to take those in fairly high dose.
But those could be beneficial. But we're talking about your curcumin, you're really what it
get up to probably five to six grams a day. Okay. Does he help at all? I mean, that I use some
heated, you know, it's kind of a localized comfort, but doesn't seem to have any lasting effect.
No, it cold, heated cold. Sometimes if you alternate hot and cold and get a pumpy action,
that might be more beneficial and everybody's a little bit different. So some people react to cold
poorly and it seems to make the pain worse. Some people react to heat poorly and it tends to make
the pain worse. So you're going to have to just experiment with that. Yeah, that's kind of what I
figured too. So, yeah, that sounds great. So thank you for that that way. I just want to ask you,
so do you sell any of these products on your site, the curcumin, or really? Yeah, so we have the
curcuclear. Yeah. So the curcuclear is the best form of curcumin right now. It's the
hydric curcumin. And one capsule is equivalent to one gram. So, and then we have buswellia.
We have a product of our own mix that is makes it a little bit less expensive called
ham. And it comes in our BAM. There's body anti-inflammatory mix. We first created it called
the brain anti-inflammatory mix, but it's really good for your whole body. It has many, and all it is
is anti-inflammatory. It's in there and we sell it at costs. So it's a powder kind of like the
mushrooms if you're, if anybody's on the mushrooms. And table, tablespoon of that a day in a mixture
that could be very good at the inflammatory mix. Can I put that in with my perfusion drink?
Yep, you can. Okay, I'm a little bit about six things that perfusion drink at this point.
So I actually somehow, even with the chagas that we've gotten inside spoke to last,
it hasn't changed the taste much. So the first greens, I think it's what it's called,
that really helps to keep the flavor, you know, in the line. Yeah, but it is funny with the
chagas because even for a couple of hours in the fridge, I go back to set some more. It is like
coffee grounds and I respect, but they go down the hatch, so everyone's going in. Yeah, thank you for that.
Yeah. So that was it from the tanks. All right, anybody else? Dr. Conner, I have a question.
Let's make me talk about detox. And they were talking about binders. And I was listening to a detox
talk by, well, the German doctor, but anyway, it was saying that sulfur, all binders,
is sulfur. And we have problems with sulfur that our bodies will reject the binders because it
considers it a stressor. And then also that will stimulate us, put it back into a sympathetic
mode. And then it'll also take, as they call it, cryable, thyroid, urea, meaning that all
your minerals are just passed through your urine because your body can't use those either. And
CVS, genetic mutations will also interfere with that. They said you have to, what you have to do is
treat the allergy or allergic response to sulfur. Can you help us with this?
So a person that has an issue with detoxing sulfur, sulfur groups is typically because of a
genetic defect. So we spoke about that. That has to do with what you just mentioned, the defect along
the CVS transaluration pathway. So you can't solve that genetic defect, you could help it. So as far
as whoever said to you that all binders sound sulfurated, that's not true at all. The ones we have
don't have that at all. So a good binder does not exit the colon. So like the ones that we have,
you don't absorb. So my definition of binder is helping with phase three. So if you remember that
chart, I don't have it here to pull up, but you have toxins that go through your bloodstream that get
transferred into your hepatocytes, your liver cells. And then through the liver cell it goes through
different phases of detoxification and those phases. What it does to that toxin, it helps that toxic
move into a soluble form so that your body could get rid of it and bind it to bile salts, which are
baited the liver through phosphatidylcholine to then be pushed through a receptor in the cell,
membrane of the liver cell into the bile duct. Whether or not you have a gallbladder or not,
it will flow through the bile duct out into the duodenum, the first part of the spola tested.
So that process is helped through using bitters. That's what Dr. Kelly talked about last time.
Bitters help stimulate that flow. Also phosphatidylcholine helps stimulate that flow because you
need phosphatidylcholine to help ache bile salts. Also, much research has shown that an herb called
Artemisid or Artemisid, I know you want to pronounce it, also helps that flow. So that is a
term, that term of that process, Dr. Kelly coid phase 2.5. Then it goes into the bile duct,
it goes into the small intestine. And in the small intestine, what you don't want to happen is you
don't want to reabsorb those. So you don't want to reabsorb those toxins. Why would you do that?
Well, you would do that if you have a leaky gut. So if you have any damage in the gut wall,
you could easily reabsorb those toxins. So you don't want to do that because you let it just
goes back through the whole process to get it overwhelmed, delivered, you cause all sorts of problems,
you just become toxic. So if you use a binder, short term after you use a bitter, and it's been
shown that anywhere between an hour and three hours after taking a bitter to stimulate that flow,
then you will bind that up into small intestine, the larger intestine, it will help bring it all the
way to toilet. So that's the purpose of that process. So, there's, yeah, if you were taking a
sulfur product and you were absorbing that sulfur product, then you were created at other toxic
best that you don't get rid of that. And the reason why that you have a reaction to something
that you don't detoxify very well is simply because it's circulating in your bloodstream
and you can't get rid of it because certain things don't cause uncertain pathways and sulfur
detoxes through the transulfiration pathway. And if you have defects in those genes, you don't do that
very well, but that's a, that's a different conversation. Then we're talking about with phase 2.5 and
you use it binders. Okay, so you use your bitters first and then you use your binder. Yep. Okay, and
does that cough, does that, is the coffee I don't want to consider phase 2.5?
The, there's, there's no studies that show that we believe that it does help with phase 2.5.
It's, we don't know the full pathway of that yet. So you're, you're just taking these two
sub, these bitters and this binders, it's just doing that when you're taking those things. Yep.
Okay. All right. And I was on auto medicine and it didn't seem to do anything for me because I
still have, I still developed the cancer with it. Yeah. All right. No other questions today.
Hopefully I got you guys to get them off some stuff. All right. Well, then we will say goodbye. I'll
get this recording up. We've been about an hour on this. Please add questions to the Facebook
group. And I thank you all of you that are really starting to chime in and help answer everybody
else's question. That's good. Everybody's got insight. Everybody's got giftedness and don't feel
shy like you don't have something to offer because you all have a lot of knowledge to offer.
And so speak up and help other people. That's where you get back to the first slides back here
and understanding your purpose. God has a purpose in this for you and it's to help others as well.
So you can open that. You don't have to wait till you're completely cured. You need to start
living it out that purpose right now and see God working it. All right. Thanks everybody.
I will say goodbye and until next week. Thank you.